[Música]
el Rey Carlos III fue Coronado como El
Monarca de Reino Unido en una ceremonia
en la abadía de Westminster de otro lado
fueron arrestadas más de 50 personas del
grupo anti monárquico a pesar de que
protestaron Con permiso de la policía
las fuerzas chechenas dicen estar listas
para asumir las posiciones que deje la
milicia Wagner en luego de que el líder
de esta organización amenazó con
retirarse de la ciudad ucraniana debido
a la falta de municiones por parte de
Rusia
y se abre una puerta de diálogo para
frenar los enfrentamientos en Sudán
representantes del ejército y de los
paramilitares llegaron a Arabia Saudita
el país anfitrión y Estados Unidos
respaldan las negociaciones cuando los
combates comienzan su cuarta semana
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle y es un gusto
acompañarlos
empezamos en Reino Unido Carlos tercero
se coronó este sábado en una ceremonia
llena de simbolismos entre la tradición
y la búsqueda de la modernidad a la que
le apunta la corona pero no logra
convencer a todos el grupo ati
monárquico rebablic organizó una marcha
en contra y la policía detuvo a su líder
graham Smith y a otras 52 personas
Andrés triviño nos cuenta que ocurrió en
la coronación
Reino Unido y la mancomunidad de
Naciones tienen un nuevo reinado con una
multitud estremecida en las lluviosas
calles de Londres Carlos y Camila
salieron desde el Palacio de buckingham
a bordo del Diamond jubile State coach
un carruaje cerrado y moderno que fue
fabricado para el cumpleaños número 80
de la Reina Isabel II a su llegada a la
abadía de Westminster a los nuevos Reyes
les esperaba una ceremonia llena de
religión simbolismo y más de 2.000
invitados el soberano de 74 años Recibió
la corona de San Eduardo utilizada desde
1661 por el Rey Carlos II un ejemplar
que pesa unos 2.2 kilos Y está formado
por un marco de oro e incrustaciones
como rubíes y granates también recibió
Cuatro espadas un cetro un orbe y dos
brazaletes uno que representa la
sinceridad y otro que simboliza la
sabiduría para posteriormente jurar a su
pueblo
el juramento de coronación se ha
mantenido durante siglos y está
consagrado en la ley está dispuesto a
hacer el juramento
después de Carlos III Camila Parker
balls fue coronada como reina en una
ceremonia diseñada para ser más corta y
con menos pompa que las anteriores
rodeados de otros miembros de la familia
real y bajo la entonación del himno
nacional Carlos III y Camila se
retiraron de la abadía de Westminster en
el Gold Coach que tiene más de 260 años
y se ha utilizado en todas las
coronaciones desde la de Guillermo IV en
1831 el destino el balcón del Palacio de
buckingham desde donde la familia real
saludó al pueblo en medio de largas
ovaciones cerrando la ceremonia de
coronación una tradición de más de mil
años y que confirma el derecho de Carlos
III y Camila a reinar pero aunque el
mundo puso los ojos en Londres la
coronación también impacta otros 14 de
países del mundo que hacen parte de la
como weld nueve de ellos están ubicados
en América a continuación lluís Muñoz
nos trae la celebraciones de Canadá y
las reivindicaciones de Jamaica
Reino Unido y otros 14 países de la
common West celebraron la coronación de
su Rey Carlos III por ejemplo este
sábado se convirtió en monarca de Canadá
el segundo país en importancia en Ottawa
a la capital las autoridades del país
también vivieron una ceremonia especial
desde nuestros comienzos como Colonia
francesa hasta hoy la monarquía ha sido
una parte integral de nuestras
instituciones y nuestra identidad
la sangre de nuestros corazones Envía un
canto de esperanza en reconocimiento a
Carlos III El rey de la commoway
Carlos tercero es rey en nueve países de
América excepto Canadá y Belice el resto
son islas del Caribe donde hay un
movimiento republicano creciente el
último en cambiar de forma de estado fue
Barbados Jamaica aspira a ser el
siguiente allí la celebración fue vista
con apatía y también de forma
reivindicativa
todavía tenemos instituciones de la
esclavitud y la colonización con
nosotros hoy en 2023 y necesitamos hacer
mucho más por lo que esta eliminación
del Rey termina simbólicamente con esa
fase de nuestro viaje
Isabel II nunca dejó de mirar a América
de hecho su primer viaje internacional
en 1953 fue a Panamá 70 años después
Carlos III tendrá dos retos cultivar los
lazos con América y sobre todo mantener
la corona en los países donde este
sábado comienza a reinar
en los grupos a favor de Rusia se
preparan para intercambiar posiciones la
milicia Wagner le pidió a los
combatientes chechenos que tomen su
lugar de aquí a que ellos se retiren al
10 de mayo Jenny y trigo sin se ha
quejado reiteradamente de que Moscú no
les envía municiones y este sábado el
líder cheno ramsam cadirov respondió que
sus combatientes están listos
en un furioso discurso lleno de
improperios El jefe del grupo
paramilitar
wagnery gojin se puso de pie sobre los
cadáveres que dijo eran combatientes de
su equipo acusó al kremlin de privar a
sus tropas de municiones y dijo que
retirara a sus fuerzas de la ciudad
ucraniana de bakmut lugar donde se Libra
La batalla más larga y Sangrienta de la
guerra Un día después de publicar el
video el tono de pregolín cambió pero su
mensaje no en un audio publicado este
sábado en Telegram pregojin dijo que
entregaría sus posiciones en bakmut a
las tropas de líder cheno ramsang
cadirov Ya estoy en contacto con sus
representantes para empezar a transferir
posiciones inmediatamente de modo que el
10 de mayo a medianoche exactamente
cuando según nuestros cálculos
agotaremos nuestro potencial de combate
nuestros camaradas ocupan nuestros
puestos y continúen el asalto de bahamut
la fecha del 10 de mayo es significativa
durante meses Wagner encabezó el asalto
a bacmut y Vladimir Putin ha anhelado
una victoria allí conmemorando así El
Triunfo soviético sobre la Alemania nazi
por su parte kadir off que ha gobernado
la República rusa de chechenia durante
la última década emitió su propio
mensaje de video diciendo que sus
fuerzas estaban listas para reemplazar
al grupo Wagner también escrito una
carta para el comandante en jefe supremo
Vladimir Putin en la que le comunicó que
estamos listos para tomar el control de
bacmut estaremos encantados de tomar el
territorio que queda allí
culpó a funcionarios del crimen de
causar la muerte y heridas a decenas de
miles de combatientes rusos alegando que
el Ministerio de defensa solo había
entregado el 32% de la munición
necesaria desde octubre quedando corto y
sin tiempo mientras Rusia se prepara
para una esperada contraofensiva
ucraniana esta Primavera
los enviados del ejército de Sudán y los
paramilitares de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido ya llegaron a Arabia Saudita para
negociar una posible tregua a pesar de
que los intentos anteriores Y el actual
no se han respetado en más de tres
semanas de enfrentamientos se calcula
que cien mil refugiados han huido a
países vecinos y otras
330.000 personas se desplazaron
internamente veamos la situación que
ella se enfrenta
es la ciudad a la que muchos pretenden
llegar
por Sudán
una posible ruta de escape para huir de
la guerra en curso con muchos hoteles
copados algunos acampan en los muelles
todos esperan conseguir un tiquete para
salir del país
cuando llega un barco a la gente le
sellan el pasaporte y se va estamos
luchando
el proceso de evacuación es muy
complicado algunas personas llevan aquí
cinco seis o incluso 10 días
cuatro aviones cargados de alimentos y
suministros médicos aterrizaron el
viernes en la ciudad costera
sin embargo la entrega de ayuda No ha
sido fácil el reto es como hacer llegar
estos suministros a donde se necesitan y
a las instalaciones sanitarias para
salvar las vidas de los pacientes
heridos tenemos que hacer al mismo
tiempo tanto a nivel superior desde el
nivel más alto posible presionando a las
partes combatientes pero lo más
importante para mí ahora operativamente
es hacerlo con el nivel local para
conseguir realmente el acceso ante el
saqueo de los convoyes Naciones Unidas
ha exigido al ejército regular y el
grupo paramilitar fuerzas de acción
rápida que garanticen el paso seguro de
la ayuda a pesar del alto al fuego los
combates continúan y la ONU advierte que
860.000 personas podrían verse obligadas
a huir de Sudán Mientras tanto Al otro
lado del mar Rojo ambos bandos
enfrentados llegaron a la ciudad Saudita
de lleda para discutir las condiciones
de una posible tregua
hubo un nuevo tiroteo en Estados Unidos
Esta vez fue en un centro comercial en
la comunidad de Allen a unos 40
kilómetros de Dallas Texas la policía
respondió y mató al tirador las
autoridades señalaron que hubo varios
heridos incluidos niños aunque no
precisaron Cuántas personas y tampoco se
refirieron a muertes la organización
ha reseñado 198 tiroteos en el país en
lo que va de 2023 la cifra más alta
desde 2016
hasta aquí las noticias volvemos en
minutos
[Música]